[Musique]
martissant vaste quartier populaire au
sud ouest de port au prince est
normalement surpeuplé
on topic les affrontements entre gangs
ont éclaté ici en juin dernier le
quartier se vide les écoles les
commerces et les marchés sont fermés
même les vendeuses de rue ont disparu la
station bus est un des rares lieux
encore fréquenter des dizaines de
chauffeurs sont toujours derrière leur
volant malgré
l'identité
ouvert aurait menti sans qu'on ait
amélioré même que nos
capacités pour le départ de la vallée
bloquer la météo n'ont plus cette
version très difficile de
martissant et incontournable pour les
chauffeurs le quartier est la seule
porte d'entrée et de sortie de port au
prince vers le sud du pays un passage
obligé stratégique que les gangs aux
prises en otage
ont découpé route fallout découper route
à tout ça ben dhiab à l'opposition band
et yves le masne offrait aux parois
kamui kobayashi non car tout est aux
abois cherche
à donner des 6 po alias car wash est
d'autant plus nerveux sur la route qu'il
a été kidnappé à deux reprises la
première fois détenu pendant trois
semaines il était convaincu qu'on allait
le tuer
je veux les voir là qu'un jour elle
continue à nous depuis dix
ans
la commune prête je dis pas tous les
lundis pour ça qu'un baby kids et au
lard et chauffer les muscles wyoming à
moins d'être au milieu d'un petit ma
prière de ma prière qui le lendemain de
l'enlèvement les ravisseurs après sa
conjointe pour lui réclament une rançon
jeudi soit phénoménal
non bon nombre sont machina mais la fin
50 vous dire elle patine nouvelles
jeunes comme l'abonnement
est bien posée l'été tel était l'état
vers l'avant nous mêmes à battre en
outre à ces familles - même timoun yo
chaque soir ou presque pas dormi
[Musique]
la mobilisation avait fui la zone qui
était devenu une zone de combat
les violences et les kidnappings sont
telles que médecins sans frontières qui
étaient dans le quartier depuis 15 ans a
fermé son hôpital il n'y a pratiquement
plus de services publics dans ce secteur
la situation sécuritaire est tellement
mauvaise qu'il n'était plus possible
pour nos staff mais également pour les
patients d'avoir accès à notre service
et donc nous avons dû
changer de structure qu on aura localisé
dans un endroit plus stable et plus
accessible à la population
la vie est quasiment impossible dans la
capitale haïtienne parce qu'il ya un
taux de violence extrêmement élevé
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup des gens ont
perdu leur vie et beaucoup d'autres sont
aussi endommagées beaucoup d'autres sont
aussi déplacés rafa un semis de travail
pour un organisme qui aide des jeunes à
sortir des gangs de rue à trouver
d'autres sources de revenus que le crime
car le kidnapping est devenue une
industrie en 2021 il y a eu près de
mails enlèvement enregistré c'est entre
15 et 20 kidnappé par semaine avec la
longue peut tout faire on peut acheter
des hommes on peut acheter
de nouvelles voitures de nouvelles
maisons on peut aussi recruter de
nouveaux soldats on peut payer des
soldats comme chef de gang le haut fait
de kidnapping rentable plus on peut
s'imposer faire grandir sa milice et son
influence politique
quand on dit leader dans sa communauté
c'est quelqu'un qui a la grande capacité
de mobiliser toute une foule au moment
des élections c'est l'idée aulas auront
la possibilité de rencontrer
les candidats et ensemble ils peuvent
s'associer trouver des avantages après
les résultats des élections et pascal
mathis en
leur pouvoir mais chacune elles ont tous
ses recours aux réseaux sociaux et
parfois à la musique le leader du groupe
qui a kidnappé car wash durant
leur complicité avec les politiciens a
anéanti la crédibilité de toutes les
institutions publiques y compris celles
des forces de l'ordre à martissant le
commissariat de police a carrément été
abandonnée
la police ça n'existe plus diniz le
chauffeur le bus et sa femme même se
faire escorter par des policiers pour
traverser martissant y risque ou au pied
des pylônes ya près
de la bassée
oubliez pas en traînant comme ça même
qu'avant je dis qu'il n'a pas le choix
de continuer conduire un bus est la
seule façon qu'il a de nourrir sa
famille lui et sa femme se résigne à
vivre la peur au ventre à chaque instant
leurs besoins que nous notamment
l'école obligés risquez-vous au même
tour toronto les mâles et les padres bud
racing foot ne descendent pas d'un bus
le couple a récemment fui la violence de
port au prince pour s'installer à jacmel
avec ses trois enfants mais caroit je
dois toujours faire le trajet vers la
capitale il doit encore passer par
martissant
oh
[Musique]